you know a lot of people are worried
about the state of the world and of the
country and you get the feeling that
we're teetering on the edge of a cliff
we're on the precipice of something you
don't know if it's too late for us to be
saved well fear no more because help is
here cardi B is running for Congress not
yet I mean but she's gonna run for
Congress she said yesterday she tweeted
I do feel like if I go back to school
and focus up I can be part of Congress I
dead-ass have so much ideas that make
sense I just need a couple of years of
school and I can shake the table yes she
dead-ass has so much ideas dead-ass
that's one word hat has so much ideas
and I think that's a great campaign
slogan for her you know cardi B I
dead-ass have so much ideas or maybe
just Cardini 2024 so much ideas it'll be
great and she'll fit right in I think I
mean this is the woman remember who
bragged about drugging and robbing men
so she she admitted to committing that
crime on multiple occasions
serious a whole series of violent
felonies she admitted to and bragged
about it so as a thief you know she'll
fit right in in Washington so I'm
looking for two that speaking of which
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren they
they dead-ass have so much ideas as well
it's just that their ideas like cardi
B's not always the best they finally
turned against each other and in a not
very shocking turn of events they these
reports have surfaced reports have
surfaced just surfaced surface like a
like a dead fish floating up to the top
of the water
nobody caused it just happened on its
own the reports just sort of oh there
they are they surfaced reports surfaced
that Bernie Sanders in 2018 met with
Elizabeth Warren and said in that
meeting that a woman cannot win the
presidency now born yet Bernie of course
has strenuously denied this but Warren
has come out issued a statement and
without without trying to sound like
he's accusing him and being a sexist she
basically is accusing him of being a
sexist this is her statement she says
Bernie and I met for more than two hours
in December 2018 to discuss the 2020
election our past work together and our
shared goals beating Donald Trump taking
back our government from the wealthy and
well-connected and building an economy
that works for everybody so these are
wealthy well-connected people who want
to take back the government from wealthy
and well-connected people by taking
control of it themselves all right among
the topics that came up was what would
happen if Democrats nominated a female
candidate I thought a woman could win he
disagreed I have no interest in
discussing this private meaning meeting
any further then she goes on I have no
interest in discussing the meeting but
let me discuss it for a minute so after
she's after she's confirmed that part of
it she said I'm not gonna yeah yeah no
he's totally a sexist but I'm not gonna
confirm it I mean we're not gonna talk
about it okay I don't wanna I don't want
to talk about it I'm just saying that
Bernie is a is a backwards bigoted
misogynist I don't want to talk about it
that's all I'm saying okay I'm just
gonna say that and then we're not gonna
talk about it anymore now Bernie fans
have of course not been too happy about
about about all this and they have
presented what I think is pretty
compelling evidence to exonerate their
man here is and this was this this was
this is now making its rounds on on
social media but this is a clip of
Bernie apparently back in 1988 with
still remarkably the same haircut in
1988 and here he is talking about women
presidents the real issue is not whether
you're black or white whether you're a
woman or a man in my view a woman could
be elected president of the United
States the real issue is whose side are
you on are you on the side of workers
and poor people or are you on the side
of big money and the corporation okay so
there you go he dead-ass had the same
ideas he had he had so much ideas even
in 1988 the same exact ideas
same hairstyle same you know ranting and
raving which you gotta respect so there
has been consistency from Bernie Sanders
the only thing that he's not consistent
on is the
thing of you know rich people are evil
and then he goes out and buys three
houses so that's a little bit of any
consistency both in terms of his
rhetoric he's been saying the same
things for forever percents you know
since since the Revolutionary War
approximately and but in 1988 he says
that yeah there could be a woman
president and now Warren claims that in
2018 30 years later he's changed his
mind even asked her and he sank and she
is saying that he changed his mind
even after he had the evidence of a
woman running for president Hillary
Clinton 2016 and winning three million
more popular votes than Donald Trump so
would seem to be pretty good evidence
that people are willing to vote for a
woman even a woman like Hillary Clinton
god help us so now I have no dog in this
fight between kooky socialists but I
have to say a couple of things here
first of all who cares if he said this
you know even if he said that a woman
can't be President which I don't believe
he said and I and again I have no reason
to take his side other than incise not
like I I like the guy but I don't
believe he exercised but even if he did
even if he dead ass did say that okay
eventually I'm gonna use that this this
slang in the proper context I don't even
know what it means I don't know what it
means
dead-ass what is that supposed to mean
how so in the in the context she used it
it sounds like a a replacement for
literally or something the way people
use literally now we're doing dead-ass
even if he dead ass did say that it's
not sexist there's nothing sexist about
it because that would be a statement of
his opinions of his opinion about about
the voting public not about women so if
he said that then what he would be
saying is that he thinks the voting
public is sexist which is sort of an
insult to the voting public but we're
used to liberals insulting people that
way I mean it'd be the same sort of
thing if as if Bernie Sanders were to
say that he doesn't think a black man
can get a fair trial in an American
Court which is the kind of thing that he
probably would say and you know for all
I think that
but would that be a statement about the
black men or is that the statement about
the court system see he's accusing the
court system of being racist in that
case in that hypothetical if you were to
say that in this case he'd be accusing
the voting public of being sexist which
is not it which is insulting and
demeaning to the American public but
again not insulting in demeaning to
women but in any case the real problem
for Warren is that she's a known liar so
there's no reason at all to believe what
she says we already know that she's not
above lying to get what she wants Bernie
on the other idea on the other hand has
bad ideas is a hypocrite would be a
dead-ass disaster for this country if
elected but there's no reason to think
that he's a then he's a liar the way
that she is I mean she's just a liar we
know that but I don't think we
necessarily know that about Bernie
Sanders as I said though I have no dog
in this fight and I'm sure the Trump is
glad to see them fighting because here's
the irony between Bernie and Warren
there are certainly enough votes there
to to win the nomination I think the
last poll I saw the RealClearPolitics
average had the combined the combined
average for Sanders and Warren together
was about 35 points combined which is
well above Biden at 26 or 27 points so
if one of them were to drop out and
endorse the other or even one of them
were to drop out and join the others
ticket then I think they would sail to
the nomination and this is exactly what
this is what exposes them both as frauds
really because this is what they would
do if they really cared about the ideas
and about beating Donald Trump and all
of that as Elizabeth Warren claims to
care about then they would that's what
they would do but instead they both stay
in because it's really about the pursuit
of power they both stay in and now
they're gonna start eating each other
alive and Joe Biden's gonna win the
nomination and then probably lose to
Donald Trump that's what's gonna happen
Bernie Sanders 78 years old probably
only a few years from death I say that
because he's
seventy-eight years old the average life
expectancy for a man in this country is
84 I think or not much higher than 84 at
least so you know however long he lives
it's not that much longer probably at
his age he's been a politician forever
and rather than retiring and enjoying
his last few years on earth he's
grasping desperately for power because
he wants it and he needs it and he will
sabotage his own party in pursuit of it
same for Elizabeth Warren it is just
it's pathetic a pathetic display but as
I said great for Trump now before we
move on a word from LifeLock if you want
a New Year's resolution that's easy to
keep here's one resolve to help protect
your identity and personal info with
life lock identity theft protection look
getting your identity stolen it's one of
those things that people think won't
happen to them but then it does right
and you learn the hard way but this is
this is one of those lessons also that
you don't want to learn the hard way
because it's very difficult to recover
from and there's no reason to learn it
the hard way because you can always get
LifeLock life lock alerts you to
potential threats to your identity they
see more than than you're able to see by
just monitoring your own credit like
they can see your info on the dark web
so they're able to rate they're able to
do a better job of monitoring things for
you then you can do for yourself and if
you have a problem life locks us-based
restoration specialists know the steps
to take to help resolve your case only
one in five identity theft victims who
had accounts open in their name
discovered their theft through a bank or
credit card company of course no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions and all businesses but
life lock is the New Year's resolution
that's not only easy to keep but it'll
help you protect what you've worked so
hard to gain in the first place so if
you've worked hard to build a life for
yourself and all the things you have
just to leave it out in the open for
someone to come and take is not a smart
move get life locked for up to 25% off
your first year go to life lock calm
slash Walsh that's life lock calm slash
Walsh for up to 25 percent off so you
remember that Jessica you Neve fellow
he's the guy who tried to sue a bunch of
salons to force them to wax his genitals
even though he has male genitals and
is a male and so it makes sense he has
male genitals males tend to have those
but he claims to be a woman and so thus
he says he is a human right to have his
genitals waxed somehow and the fact that
they wouldn't do it is an infringement
on his basic human rights so you
remember that and he's also the guy who
allegedly has sexually harassed girls
minors online and he's generally just a
creep and a bad person in so many ways
anyway he's in court again after another
dust-up with the law and a reporter on
his way out of the court a reporter
tried to come up and talk to him and
here's how that went down
YOUnique will you be pleading guilty
what no no don't touch me don't tell me
get away from me go away I'm crazy get
away get up go away from me stay away
from me get away from me now right now
you hurt me on the police on you I don't
give a sh get away from me you stay away
from me I'm so there the reporter says
that he was punched in the back of the
head and assaulted which you can't see
that but you can kind of hear it and
here's all I want to say about this
we've seen these kinds of videos so
often not just with you Nev but these
sjw's assaulting people whether it's at
at a Tifa rally or it's it's somebody
assaulting pro-lifers or whatever it is
we see these videos all the time with
sjw bullies assaulting people at will
and getting away with it and when I say
getting away with it I don't mean
legally now legally they do often get
away with it and in that there's no
legal repercussions in the end but I'm
talking about physically and I'm really
tired of this so I don't mean to victim
blame here the the guy the reporter the
journalist who is being assaulted but
all I'm saying is if you're being
assaulted by a raging psychopath SJW
fight back ok it's not like you saw you
Nev they're not exactly a UFC champion
we're talking about here so fight back
hit back
this reporter would have been entirely
within his rights to knock your knees
teeth out if somebody's assaulting you
you can hit them you should it's not
just you can you should do that stand
your ground stand up for yourself you
don't have to run away or just you know
start calling for help or try to just
get it on video yeah fine get it on
video but you can also at the same time
defend yourself
so defend yourself don't allow yourself
to be hit in the head you know respond
with force you have every legal and
moral right to do so that's what I'm
saying people have gotten way way way
too comfortable doing this you see these
videos all the time and it just seems
like people in this country today
they're so comfortable you see someone
you know you don't like or they're
making a political point you don't like
or they're annoying you let's go up and
punch him at least on the left that's
what they've gotten very accustomed to
responding that way and I guess why not
because nobody ever seems to respond
they just do it and then they walk away
and you know we give the video goes
viral and we talk about all those
violent leftist I'm sick of that just
what worried I mean this guy of all
people this you need guy you're gonna
let him hit you in the head you let him
do that this is a it's the only way this
is the same thing you know that parents
used to tell us and parents don't say
this anymore I guess because it's it's
endorsing violence but back in my day
you know when I was a kid we used to be
told that you got a bully on the
playground maybe the one thing that
bully needs is a sock to the nose you
know sometimes people need that and I
think that's what we're seeing here I
mean if they if they never get that if
there's never any immediate
repercussions for acting this way then
they'll just keep doing it and it's for
their good anyway because you know not
everybody in the world
is quite so willing to be hit in the
face or attacked and you know you never
know when you go up and treat somebody
the wrong way or when you treat the
wrong person that way you never know how
they'll respond sometimes it could be
for their own good you respond in kind
you know just physically defending
yourself proportionally maybe they learn
their lesson and maybe that stops them
from in the future going after someone
who maybe will respond not so
proportionally you never know so just
just defend yourself
everybody that's what I'm saying all
right a certain a professor college
professor and once you see the clip here
you're not going to be surprised that
this is a college professor we're
dealing with but her name doctor Shola
moles chug chug bam EMU I think Sagwa
MIMO I think I pronounced that correctly
dr. Chawla well we'll call her for short
she was on on TV this morning British TV
talking about the reaction that Megan
Markel and and you know the reaction to
the Megan Markel and Prince Harry
situation and she said that the people
criticizing Markel are not only racist
but so obviously racist that she doesn't
need to explain why they're racist and
in fact if you ask for an explanation
that only proves that you're racist
watch I think the difficulty here for a
lot of people who said they do not
understand this thing and the thing is
that it is not the job of black people
and ethnic minorities to educate white
people on racism that's perpetrated by
white people white folks need to go
educate themselves on the racism they
perpetrate the reason why the racism
experience by making feels so personal
and it deeply resonates with a lot of
people it's because it's symptomatic of
the culture of racism in the United what
what examples do you have is it that is
another problem when people ask keep
asking what examples it makes me
question it it makes me question where
have you been the last two years what
reading what have you been some
criticism right I haven't personally
read anything that I could say was based
on and this is race this is part of the
problem and let me explain what racism
looks like from the lens of white
privilege white privilege whitewashes
racist and inflammatory language as
unconscious bias so this is great
you see how you see how the game is
played and you couldn't ask for a better
illustration of it you couldn't ask for
a better explanation of the left wing
playbook that you get here so you've got
dr. Shola claiming that the criticism of
megyn Markel is racist and then you've
got this very careful very hesitant
white guy just ever so cautiously asking
he's very cautious about it ever so
cautiously saying hey i mean do you have
an example of this you're saying racist
kidding i mean can you give one example
just so we understand we don't you see
that's the problem only racists asked
for examples oh okay well never mind
never mind and then she goes into this
whole spiel using a lot of big words and
a lot of lingo and jargon about
whitewashing and unconscious bias and
the camouflaging of racist behavior and
so on and so forth and all of this just
to herself camouflage the fact that she
has no evidence for what she's saying no
examples to provide she's saying all of
this criticism of mega Marvel's racist
okay well just get might use you there's
a lot of it apparently so can you cite
one example of racist criticism against
megyn Markel I'm not even saying that it
doesn't exist but just tell me what
you're talking about I want to
understand what you're saying I'm trying
to listen to you I'm being an active
listener and so there's a phenomenon
that you're describing and so I'm saying
give me a few more details on that
phenomenon so I can understand it but no
we're supposed to take her at her word
on face value because she's black and
we're white and that's all there is to
it and that's it just that yes it you
can't you that's all that you need to
know meanwhile personally I'm not even
I'm not a critic of megyn Markel I don't
care about the issue they can do
whatever they want as far as I'm
concerned
but what and as I said a few days ago I
sort of admire the fact that she was
able to get her spouse to break up with
his with his with you know with he was
she was able to she was basically able
to break up with her in-laws which I
think at some level all spouses across
the country can sort of watch with with
maybe a tinge of of envy but anyway from
what I've seen the criticism of mega
margul is based on the belief that some
people have that she wants to sabotage
the royal family and she's a gold digger
basically in it for attention and fame
and whatever else now you know I don't
know if that's true or not and I think
if there's any bias against her or if
there was any bias in the in the first
place it's probably more of an
anti-american bias from a British if
there was ever any British bias against
her from the beginning before all this
happened maybe there was a little bit of
an anti-american thing going on which
even that I don't know problem with that
I I understand I get I don't care if
some of the Brits felt like hey we don't
want an American in the world family
yeah whatever fine they want it to be
their own little special Club it's say
you know I'm fine with that but and it
is true that Megan Markel did succeed in
tearing Prince Harry away from the
family so the the people you know in in
Britain who said that they're concerned
that she's some sort of on some sort of
sabotage mission well it seems like they
were vindicated in that view because of
what happened and it is a pretty unusual
thing right what's happened here so the
woman on the show is sitting there and
saying oh well the moment a black woman
dismantles the royal family suddenly
it's a problem well I don't know I think
the Brits would have a problem with that
no matter who did it no matter what
their race is it's it's it's kind of a
really unusual and unprecedented thing
and they end to a lot of British people
that's a big deal and they probably
react this way no matter what
I think to them having a prince Prince
Harry stepped down from the family
whatever that means that's that's as I
said it's a big deal
so people are reacting to an
unprecedented dramatic move in a
dramatic way but all this person sees is
race of course now when a follow-up post
on Twitter
Shola says people triggered by true the
truth of racism or sorry people
triggered by the truth of hashtag racism
and hashtag white privilege can't handle
the truth
it's reprehensible that we not only have
to defend ourselves from racism but then
we're expected to exploit it and also
bear the brunt of denials of our lived
experience how dare you ask us to
explain we've made a claim and now you
expect us to justify that claim to
prevent present evidence no evidence is
a racist conspiracy by the way lived
experience can we can we forever and
always do away with that is it racist me
to say this can we do away with the
lived experience phrase or maybe don't
do a wave them because it's it's it is
it is one of those keywords one of those
red flags if you ever hear somebody UNAC
Lee used the phrase lived experience
then you know that this is a pretentious
gas bag and you could probably ignore
everything they're saying lived
experience this is my lived experience
let me ask you is it possible to have
for you to have an experience that you
didn't live is there such a thing as an
unlived experience this is my unlived
experience yeah I experienced it but I
wasn't living at the time I guess I
don't know maybe zombies maybe we need
to step your life between lived
experience and an undead experience in
case of a zombie apocalypse I don't know
I can't figure it out I can't figure out
why you need to lived in front of that
except that this is just one of those
dumb things that you get from especially
from pretentious college professors
where they just add in extra words to
make something sound more profound so
we're
had to lived on experience because it
sounds more profound than just saying
experience like a normal person let's
well before we move on a quick word from
rock Auto you know going to the auto
parts store is not always the most fun
experience are speaking of experience my
lived experience of going to auto parts
stores not always the best because you
drive all the way there you go in things
aren't always the best organized and at
least in my opinion I never agree with
the way that stores are organized I
always think I'm always judging the way
they've organized every whether it's the
grocery store Auto Parts and then I
write angry letters as you might expect
to the management anyway but you go in
you know things aren't well organized
and nine times out of ten what happens
is they're good looking for something
and they have to just order it anyway so
what's the point of that why why not
just cut out the middleman go to
rockauto.com
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil new carpets for
the car whatever they whatever it is
you're looking for whether it's for your
your classic or your daily driver you
get everything you need in a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is super easy
to navigate which is especially
important for me as someone who you know
I wouldn't really call myself a car guy
I have a car I can change the tire I can
do stuff like that but not exactly a car
expert and it's one of my you know it's
it's it's one of my failings as a man I
admit but I don't like to have my
failings you know throw it in my face
all the time and so you go to
rockauto.com it just makes it really
easy to navigate and you know where
you're going there and you don't have to
be a car expert to navigate the site
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
amazing selection reliably at low prices
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
Walch in there how did you hear about us
box so that they know that we sent you
well Stephen King is about to be
cancelled
everybody JK rowling was canceled
now Stephen King Stern so all of the
mega-rich liberal authors are getting
their turn in the cancellation chamber
so of course the Oscar nominees were
released yesterday and there's always a
problem right every time the Oscar
nominees come out there's always some
group that's been persecuted there's not
enough black people nominated or there's
not enough women or there's not enough
gay people or there's not you know maybe
they forgot to nominate a representative
number of gender-fluid Mexican
pansexuals whatever it is whatever the
case may be there's always some group
that's been less left out so this time
around it's women women get to be the
victims this time so they won the
contest if you're a woman
congratulations you won the victim hood
contest with the Oscars this time around
and maybe if you are a woman you may not
realize if you've just been I don't know
out living your life and not worried
about the Oscars you may not realize
that you've been victimized by the Oscar
nominee list but I it is my pleasure to
inform you that in fact you have been so
you have you know you can notch a couple
extra a couple other notches in the belt
of victimization there because no woman
was nominated for Best Director now the
best director nominees are apparently
Martin Scorsese Quentin Tarantino bong
joon-ho Sam Mendes and todd phillips
those are the five nominees for Best
Director Greta Gerwig directed Little
Women and was not included and that's
the issue that's where the persecution
comes in Stephen King got himself
cancelled because he had the nerve to
suggest that with art all that matters
is quality not diversity he had the the
gumption now I of course he tweeted this
out is that well don't you think that
and they always do it so innocently and
like they it's like they really don't
realize what's about to happen so
Stephen King tweeted and said you know
it seems like with art all that really
matters is the quality it's not so much
about diversity he's just sort of
whistling past the graveyard just sort
of strolling along doesn't realize that
he's saying something that's about to
get him about to get him gang tackled by
the pitchfork mob and so he says that
and then
predictably they all descend upon him
I'm just wondering
of course you know there's there's no
point even in even analyzing what he
said of course he's a hundred percent
right obviously it's it's when it comes
to art or whether it's film or music or
books or whatever it is I think what
should matter to us as readers or
viewers or listeners is does it speak to
us is it is it is it good you know you
look at the quality and especially when
it comes to rewarding into handing out
awards the idea is what's the best now
that can be hard to judge with something
like a film there's a lot of subjective
elements to it but the concept is
supposed to be with Best Director who
are the five people who did the best job
of directing makes no difference there
their demographic group makes no
difference obviously what I'm wondering
that people saying the Greta Gerwig
should be should have been nominated for
Little Women who-who are we kicking out
okay so you got Scorsese and Tarantino
two of the best directors of our time
and they both released highly acclaimed
films this year I didn't think either of
those films whether it once upon a time
in Hollywood and the Irishman I don't
think either of them were close to their
best movies but they still these are
still great directors two of the best
still alive today with with two movies
that were good movies that were
certainly very well received by critics
so obviously they're gonna be in and
then you've got bong joon-ho did
parasite which I haven't seen yet I'm
planning to watch it tonight I've heard
that it's I mean it's it's it's being
hailed as a masterpiece and anyway he's
not white so I would think that he's
okay to nominate then you've got Sam
Mendes and he did 1917 which I did see a
few days ago and I thought was
spectacular if you haven't seen that
movie yet you know it's it's I know
there are a lot of people especially if
you're married and you have kids you
don't get out to the theater very often
even if you don't have kids maybe you
don't go very often because it's
expensive and it's just not worth the
trouble and besides you can just watch
on Netflix right when it comes out or
watch it on demand but
this is one of those movies that it'll
be it to be enjoyable to watch on your
regular TV at home but it's one of those
movies that I think the theater
experience is worth is actually worth
the price that you pay for it and I
thought it was was great one of the
criticisms of 1917 that I've read is
that well the two criticism number one
you've got to what is called a gimmick
what the critic would call a gimmick of
the whole movie is presented as if it's
one long shot or you're following these
guys and the camera doesn't really break
away from them there's no cuts and it's
it's one long extended shot for two
hours now of course in reality there
were there were cuts but they just
edited it together so that didn't look
like it I didn't think it would I didn't
to me it didn't come across like a
gimmick I thought that that method
really helped to immerse you in the
experience and I don't think it would be
the same movie I don't think it'd be
quite as good if without that then the
other criticism I've read is that the
characters aren't very fleshed out and
so it's sort of like you're watching a
video game it's like you're watching a
first-person shooter you're watching
somebody else play video game for two
hours and I you know the people saying
that I don't know what movie they
watched I thought that these characters
were very well fleshed out in subtle
ways this is a problem that war movies
have you know often sits it's something
that something you run into with war
movies it can be difficult while you're
trying to tell the story to also make
these characters real characters and not
just caricatures yeah that's a problem
that even I think saimin Private Ryan
had to a certain extent where a few of
the characters like Tom Hanks's Ken I
think it's the greatest war movie of all
time one of my favorite movies of all
time Saving Private Ryan
but even that movie I think Steven
Spielberg struggled a little bit to give
to you know gives real layers to these
characters and to some of them to turn
them into real people and not just
cartoons basically so it's always a
struggle with war films I thought that
that mandates did a good noble job of it
in in a subtle way
there's a few the you get a few scenes
with these guys that kind of show you
the development of the character and it
shows you extra layers there that
weren't immediately obvious so anyway
that was a great movie and I think
deserves to be deserves to be nominated
in top films with with Joker one of the
most talked-about films of the decade a
huge success obviously which of course
just cuz the movies a huge success
doesn't make it a great movie but this
is also I think in my view a really good
film and I think it would be weird to to
and and and also Todd Phillips is
presenting a very different take on this
iconic character an iconic well-worn
character he's presenting a different
take so I think that deserves as well
which of these guys do you kick out just
so you can nominate credit Gerwig I
haven't seen Little Women I admit and I
don't plan to watch it I admit that too
but it I'm skeptical that the that film
and the directing job done there is
really better than any of the five we
just I just mentioned all right let's
move on to emails but seriously go watch
nineteen seventeen if you haven't
watched yet okay by the way don't to
forget to mention if you're not already
a subscriber you're really missing out
and right now using promo code Walsh
you'll get 10% off any plan that you
choose head over to Daley wire.com slash
subscribe and pick the plan that's right
for you for as little as ten bucks a
month members will get our articles ad
free you get access to our live
broadcast get the show library the full
three hours of Ben Shapiro every day
select bonus content you get access to
the mail but mail bag much more than
that as well plus our new all-access
tier gets you live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben Shapiro Andrew
Klavan Michael Knowles
plus our daily wire writers the special
guests we bring them all in and it's
always a really interesting discussion
there so don't forget you also get the
greatest of all beverage vessels as well
the left is tears tumbler so you want to
get on that now okay this is from Jason
says you got on the topic of free will
again you had mentioned that you make
the decision to lift a mug or make a
grilled cheese what if those are
decisions what if those decisions were
to be made as they are inconsequential
you mentioned you could go kill someone
if you wanted but really you can't your
moral code wouldn't allow it now a
morality is subjective to a degree
within each person and changes through
time what if God guides us through
morality what if those lacking morals do
so because of God putting events in
motion
we know morals come from God what if
this is why curious as to your thoughts
on this okay so I'm gonna try to home in
Jason on what I think are your your is
your primary point talking about free
will you say that well I really can't do
whatever I want because my moral code is
there and I guess part of your point is
I'm not the one who put my moral code in
place necessarily so so then I don't
have free will I guess maybe that's your
point so when I say that I'm choosing to
lift my mug yeah I could choose to do
that that's an inconsequential thing but
I can't really go out and kill somebody
because my moral code would prevent me
but that's the point
Jason that my moral code which does rule
out and prohibit killing someone it
actually cannot prevent me from doing it
I could if I wanted to make the decision
in spite of what my moral code says to
go out and kill somebody contrasting
that with like computer programming now
your computer is programmed to do a
certain thing and it is prevented then
from doing other things that it's not
programmed to do unless it malfunctions
and something goes wrong but a more but
a computer can't say to itself well I'm
programmed to do such and such but I
really don't want to do that so I'm
going to do this instead we can do that
we can say to ourselves and all of us
have said it hopefully with not with
something as serious as killing somebody
but we've all said to ourselves at times
in our life well I know this is wrong I
shouldn't do it but I'm gonna do it
anyway because I want to because I've
decided that there's something else that
I want and it's worth breaking my moral
code to obtain it and we always find out
that it wasn't worth it in the end but
you know we're stupid so we keep doing
it anyway but them but we still have
free will because we still have that
choice so the fact that I can
theoretically the option is open to me
to go on a killing spree if I want to
but I don't so I don't write and that's
the difference that's where free will I
think still applies this is from
Santiago says hi Matt I love your shot
let's do it every day I'm like a
beautiful commute from work I find
myself in the rare position of
disagreeing with you in relation to your
counter-argument to Sam Harris's
refutation of free will I agree with
your conclusion that free will exist but
I think that you got Harris's argument
wrong as I understand it his argument is
not that if you had the same mental
illnesses and bad home environment of a
serial killer
you would also be a serial killer what
he is saying is that if you had exactly
the same brain down to the neural
connections and all the same
neurotransmitters and other chemical
molecules in the exact same position you
would do exactly the same thing in other
words he is saying that our decisions
boil down to just one big complex
chemical reaction going on in our brain
as such if you knew every single
molecule in every single position you
would theoretically predict every every
decision or could theoretically predict
every decision actually the whole
argument of determinism is that the
universe itself is one big chemical
reaction that should be predictable if
we know all the variables this idea is
represented by the concept of Laplace's
daemon therefore Harris argues freewill
is just an illusion that arises from the
fact that the chemical reaction in our
brain is so complex that making exact
predictions of the outcome is hard
however in theory even your decision to
lift your mug should be predictable if
you have enough initial information this
is indeed a powerful argument but I
think it has a big flaw the burden of
proof is on him the claim that the
universe is deterministic and that all
that influences the physical world is
just matter and physical energy is a
tremendously strong one and I do not
think there is a whale that's the way to
scientifically or philosophically prove
it
what I'm saying is that I do not think
that your argument refutes Harris's but
I also do not think that Harris's
argument is a valued refutation of
freewill in fact I think that there is
no way to conclusively prove that our
decisions are deterministic or that Free
Will exists yeah and that is an aspect
of Harris's argument I don't think I I
thought that I provided a relatively
accurate summary of
argument now he did say I think there
was one line in in his book in his
argument I think maybe was encapsulates
and it was the strongest line in the
book where he's talking about you know
if I talk about it I think it was a
murderer you know he said well if I were
to change places with a murderer what
I'd do the exact same thing would I also
commit those murders and then he said if
I were to switch places Adam for Adam
like what you're talking about here like
I were to switch switch even even right
down to my atoms we were to switch well
then in that case I would just be that
other person and I would do everything
that are doing which i think is what
you're talking about here but I still
say my response to Harris I think is uh
is correct and I have to say Santiago
I'm a little bit biased I think I like
my response better than yours because
getting into this burden of proof things
yeah I don't I don't like that I don't
both theists and atheists met no matter
what the discussion is both theists and
atheists
will try to get into the burden of proof
argument and and then you get into this
food fight back and forth where no the
Boonton burden of proof is on you know
it's on you and then it's back and forth
who's hurt who is the burden of proof on
I just I don't think that's the
strongest platform on which to have this
discussion and I think that Harris or
someone who's determinist could just as
easily say that no the burden of proof
is on you I say that everything is
determined by physical matter you're
saying that there's some other force out
there like a soul and spiritual force
that we can't see burden is on of proof
is on you to prove that because we can't
see it and according to everything we
know from science it's it's all comes
down to matter so no the burden approves
on you I think that would be his
response and I think it's a pretty fair
response if you want if you want to get
into the burden of proof contest I'd
rather not get into that contest and so
I still say my answer is pretty simple
but it remains in place
whether we're talking about chemical
reactions in the brain or we're talking
about how you were raised and those sort
of external factors the fact remains
that as a human being when we're
deciding what to do
we have met we have countless infinite
really theoretical options and we could
theoretically do any of those things so
if I'm holding a gun in my hand
theoretical option that I could pick up
the gun and shoot somebody but if I
don't it's because I decided not to and
to me that's what free will is there are
a whole lot as I said yesterday there
are a whole lot of things that will
influence my decision one way or another
and if I do decide to pick it up and
shoot somebody you could you could you
know you could probably start looking at
my background you could look at the way
that I was raised you could you could
look inside my brain and you could find
a lot of things that push me in that
direction but at the end of the day that
was an option of many different options
and it's the option that I chose and
that's all I think that's all freewill
is it's just it's just it's a it's a it
is a it is a based on the fact that as
human beings we have many theoretical
options for what we do and what we say
and so the only way that I could see to
disprove freewill is to disprove that
those options even exist you would have
to say that you know I have the gun I
decide not this you're someone you have
to say that shooting someone wasn't even
a theoretical option it wasn't an option
at all but I think that's
just on the face of it clearly incorrect
all right
so but it's an interesting discussion at
any rate and you know we talk about
determinism and freewill and everything
and how we've been talking about the
last few days it's it's been sort of an
atheist for this verse theists thing but
it's not just that because of course in
the past we've talked about this with
we're you know with the different
Christian views of this and there are
Christians who say that there's no such
thing as free will so doesn't have to
break down on a theist versus theists
lines okay we'll leave it there though
thanks everybody for listening thanks
for watching
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you want to delve the depths of leftist
madness head on over to the Michael
Noel's show where we examine what's
really going on beneath the surface of
our politics and bask in the simple joys
of being right
[Music]
you